[Music]
good morning and welcome to this
morning's debate the hypocrisy of the
good
from fervent socialists to devout
christians many have sought to live by a
strict moral code yet from the gulags to
the inquisition it has often been those
with the strictest codes who have
perpetrated the greatest crimes is this
just accidental or is there something
about a strict morality that makes
hypocrisy unavoidable should we see such
terrible outcomes as a sign of the
frailty of humans rather than a threat
to the moral principles themselves or is
it possible that seeking to rigorously
and universally enforce any moral code
blinds the adherent to the real life
consequences
should we conclude that while a
framework of good action is valuable an
attempt to subsume all human behavior
within a strict code of rules is not
only impossible but dangerous
well to help me answer those questions
we have a fantastic panel of speakers
i'm very uh delighted to welcome
our first of our three speakers ej temel
kuran who is an award-winning turkish
journalist author and previous
television presenter she's published 12
books including how to lose a country
and her upcoming book 10 choices for a
better now i'm also joined by david
chandler david is a professor of
international relations at the
university of westminster and the
founding editor of the journal of
intervention and state building
with 20 books published david is a major
authority in his field known for his
analysis of international policy
including humanitarian intervention
and last but not least i'm joined by
julian badgini
julian is the author of numerous
best-selling books on philosophy and
co-founder of the philosopher's magazine
his books include the ego trick how the
world thinks and most recently the
godless gospel he's currently academic
director of the rural institute of
philosophy welcome to you all thank you
so much for joining us so the way this
is gonna go i'm gonna give you a first
question and you will have three minutes
to lay out your pictures before we
really dig into it i'm gonna kick off if
i may um this first question does a
strict morality necessarily lead to
dangerous hypocrisy aj do you want to
kick us off with that one sure sure good
morning to everyone
well the simple answer is yes but the
hypocrisy is not in the word good yet in
the word of strictness
it is the power
and therefore the ability to impose is
what corrupts the good and eventually
all that is good due to the political
sins of autocratic regimes in near
history many today tend to think that
the search for the good and eventually
all morality is hypocritical and that's
a dangerous thing i would say there is
also the angled fact that the human
with his unbearable practicality can
utilize the most intricately woven high
moral values and turn them into tools of
oppression
the vulgarity of the masses has the
ability to degrade a moral value
to a daily practice no matter how
flawlessly constructed it is in theory
it is always a very small minority who
keep the intrinsic meaning of the moral
value they keep it for the future
generations despite the corrupting
practicality of the masses
the oppressive morality of the
capitalist system is still rarely
discussed we always talk about gulags or
chinese cultural revolution and the
hypocrisy of the good in this system
still does not get the theoretical
beating that it deserves
what is
the good in today's dominant culture of
capitalism is really a popular topic
therefore we easily dismiss the fact
that the radical evil that is very
present in today's global politics is in
fact arising from the innate hypocrisy
of the good in the capitalist morality
i had to think about the hypocritical
good in capitalist morality in order to
understand the global rise of the new
authoritarianism my initial focus was
the shamelessness in fact
while writing how to lose a country i
noticed that
all the right-wing populist regimes
regardless of the country render
shamelessness as a political tool and
eventually shamelessness become a
cultural identity
well our dominant culture tends to
associate shame with bodily desire yet
they utilized shamelessness in today's
politics derives from the
damaging act on human dignity therefore
in order to oppose this and must moral
crime on human dignity we have to define
the good and do it through
what is at stake namely human dignity
i'm not sure if we can invent
a good that is immune to corruption
yet humankind's determination to search
for the good is certainly a moral value
and i think it is incorruptible and we
cannot describe that kind of good
hypocritical
thank you miriam thank you aj for that
really strong opener lots of food for
thought there and julian could i pick
that up with you does a strict morality
necessarily lead to a dangerous
hypocrisy three minutes
okay well first of all edges but i agree
with a lot of what i just said actually
although we might want to go back to a
specific world of capitalism in this
because
um i'm a bit concerned that we tend to
lump a lot of things together under that
label but look i mean i think so i'm
basically agreeing but i think to sort
of try and understand this properly i
think we need to make a few distinctions
that's our favorite game as philosophers
and one thing about this about
strictness when you mean a strict
morality
i think we've got to distinguish a
strict or you might say a rigid morality
over a demanding one i think some of the
most admirable moralities that we've had
in our world are very demanding
um for example i'm not a christian
myself but the kind of
jesus implores people to be that be the
perfect we can't be perfect but he says
you should try to be perfect that's
really really demanding that's not the
same as being strict or rigid so it's
very important to sort of recognize the
fact that if we're kind of
pointing the finger at rigid morality
uh it doesn't mean that we should
favor instead a kind of a lacks morality
a kind of anything goes do what you like
there's another distinction too i think
i think this is perhaps the key one i
think aj really pointed to this
it's it's the dogmatism really it's not
the strictness tends to go together with
dogmatism but it's not necessarily
exactly the same thing
and it's the idea that and by dogmatism
that is it's not necessarily the same
thing as a conviction so it is that
belief that not only is this right but
this must be imposed on everybody
everybody must follow
so again you can compare that to another
form of strictness if you take
buddhist monasteries right i mean
there have been corruption in buddhist
monasteries too so i don't
say that they're they're they're the
angels the highest angels but in a lot
of like buddhist monasteries life is
very very strict they live according to
very very strict rules about the times
they wake up etc etc but the ethos in
the best versions of these monasteries
is not that this is something we must go
and impose on everybody else it's
something we choose to do ourselves we
live by this code and that doesn't lead
to necessarily at all to hypocrisy and
so forth i think the final point just to
end on which perhaps ties them up is
you know moral conviction has been
extremely powerful positive change for
good you know people standing up to
uh redshirt
on in in turkey are doing so from a very
strong moral conviction and that's
really important and i think this is the
danger of like thinking that the we
should retreat instead some kind of
moral laxity but i think the the thing
that makes a difference is whether it's
a moral conviction is whether it has
what we might call this epistemic
conviction in other words it's not just
that i really believe in this value it's
right but i believe has a status of a
kind of a absolute certainty a piece of
knowledge which cannot be challenged
that that is 5000 thank you julian as
well for not just those brilliant points
but but for keeping to time um uh david
i'm going to put it to you now does a
strict morality necessarily lead to a
dangerous hypocrisy we've got lots lots
of great points already on this
i guess i want to make
two points
um around this
and
the first is some is along the lines of
a chase and maybe the second speaks to
julian's slightly
and
um
the question is about is what is it
about this strict morality that may or
may not necessarily lead to hypocrisy
and
i want to sort of come from
a slightly different angle that i think
we have to start from the world that we
live in what is it about the world that
we live in that that means that maybe or
maybe not strict morality leads to
hypocrisy and
i just want to firstly follow up a bit
on aj's point the first thing about the
world we live in is power relations
hierarchies um
yeah in that sort of a world any type of
strict morality that can be imposed is
doubtlessly going to lead to problems
because there's less accountability
problems of representation
uh problems of exclusion and we all know
that you know power power corrupts and
all the rest of it whether it's like
literally corrupting or just the
inability to see because the way that we
think about the world is normally shaped
sociologically politically economically
around our interests and in a world of
competing interests then the more
morality the more
as julian says the more that can be
imposed the more potentially dangerous
it is so that's not really sort of
rocket science to say that as long as we
live in that sort of world any sort of
strict morality is potentially dangerous
and hypocritical but more importantly
i'd like to pick up on julian's second
point about the epistemic conviction the
knowledge conviction
and there's something else about the
world even beyond the problem of power
relations that is it's a world of
differences we do not live
in a flat universal world where
everything equals the same thing
everything causes things in a sort of a
linear and reductionist way in a world
where different policies different ideas
they might work in one time and place
you unlikely to work in another time and
place you have a wonderful moral policy
around health around the environment
around cures around industry manufacture
whatever it is you realize later on
different time of place um
or even it may well be contested in the
same time and place but yeah that
doesn't actually work if you think about
the climate crisis that we're at the
moment those are all unintended
consequences those are all um products
of things that people weren't thinking
about at the time because the world
doesn't keep on going in exactly the
same way and so there's less broader
issues to think about moral codes how
could they possibly be valuable across
time and space and difference so thank
you
thank you so much for that david thank
you to all of our panelists so far so
now we're going to kick off with our
first theme
of the debate
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you